hallo ich in meiner lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen serie
und zwar minecraft guide und zwar
behandelt diese serie immer in einer
folge zeige ich euch halt drei sachen
die ihr eventuell noch nicht immer
minecraft wusstet und am ende wird es
immer noch zu einem fun fact com also
dort werde ich euch etwas zeigen was
ganz witzig ist über minecraft und zwar
würde ich sagen wir fangen dann direkt
mal an das ist ein kleiner ersatz der
mythen show und was ich auch wieder
machen werde ist dass ich eure skills
anziehen werde das heißt die komplett
skins in die kommentare schreiben
und einfach irgendwelche fun facts die
ich von euch dann eventuell nehmen werde
und dann im video vorstellen werde so
dass die breite öffentlichkeit ist es
sehen wird so die erste sache was ich
hier vorbereitet habe ist weekends alle
man läuft hier über eis drüber und dann
schlittert man so ein bisschen an sich
laufend ich stehe da ich kann das mal
ganz kurz auf 15 zeigen so schneider
immer so ein bisschen
natürlich zeigt euch nochmal von hier
ich sprinte und da steht hat man so ein
bisschen wenn es unter einem normalen
ganzen block ist schlittert man
natürlich nicht aber wenn eis unter
harfst apps ist schlittert man auch gut
so da sieht man es darstellt hat man
mich auch das ist ganz komisch und
zweitens sollte man dort nicht
schillernd ist entweder ein bug oder
halt einfach so gemacht war eigentlich
kann es natürlich nicht durch einen hart
wirken der vor allem auch so aus stein
das aber man stellt immer ein bisschen
das ist genau der gleiche effekt wie auf
diesem eis also ist auch kein bisschen
weniger es ist einfach genauso und wenn
ich 2 half tipps übereinander packe dann
spielt man nicht
also auftritte auf half the pitt
hartmann und auf ganzen blöcken nicht
über am eis und auf alles ja allgemein
immer so das war jetzt erstmal die erste
sache so kommen wir nun zur zweiten
sache und zwar ist es dass mit den
druckplatten und zwar kennt jetzt alle
wenn man auf eine druckplatte draufgeht
geht natürlich die tür offen wenn man
untergeht ist die tür wieder zu er seit
einem der letzten updates ist dazu
gekommen dass wenn ich ein pfeil auf die
druckplatte schieße dass diese dann
aufgeht wenn ich den fall wieder
wegnehmen
dass die tür dann auch wieder zugeht
also ich schieße weit aufgemacht aber
wenn ich einfach mal so ein fall drauf
schieße dann bleibt die turner natürlich
offen solange der fall dort ist wenn ich
natürlich hier ein fall dran schießt an
den block passiert natürlich gar nichts
allerdings wenn man
sein blog ist ja in diesem text steckt
zumindest acht pixel 16 32 pixel
allgemein hoch und 16 pixel der hälfte
wenn ich um die unteren 16 pixel schieße
passiert gar nichts wenn ich dagegen
schießt wenn ich allerdings da oben
gegen schieße dann geht die tür trotzdem
auf und sowie dazu also haben die hat
die obere hälfte des blockes genau die
gleiche wirkung liegt die obere seite
des blockes also das mit der druckplatte
mal ganz kurz
hier unten es geht gar nix da passiert
was und obendrauf oder schon feilt sage
ich euch nochmal so war wieder
aufgenommen also in der oberen hälfte
des blockes auf der druckplatte passiert
etwas und in der unteren hälfte passiert
gar nichts ich denke das wusstet ihr
auch noch nicht so die dritte sache die
ich euch nun zeigen werde ist wenn ihr
mit einem meint eine strecke runter tat
beziehen darunter fällt und dann hier
unten in den wasserbecken reinfeldt dann
bekommt ihr trotzdem fall schaden egal
ob ins wasser fällt
oder auch nicht die bekommt so oder so
viel schaden so ich setzte mich jetzt
mal ganz spezielles mein gehabt habe
mich extra schon in survival mode
gemacht drücke den knopf war dieser
stelle tolle strecke runter und platsch
kontrakt fiel der schwerkraft zum opfer
dachten meine ganzen tag herum
ich bin jetzt einfach hier wieder läuft
am ende des kurzen und ihr sind papst
schon gesehen dass ich dort bei
gestorben bin und zwar ganz einfach egal
von welcher höhe er unterteilt auf 104
blöcke sind ihr bekommt trotzdem fall
schaden einfach weil ihr in einem kart
sitzt hallo wie geht's jetzt gemeint hat
jetzt gehe ich gerade unter cool so und
jetzt dazu worauf wir alle gewartet habt
und zwar der fun fact und zwar der fun
fleck diesmal ist dass die sounds von
einem gas gesetzt gerade mal ganz kurz
diese sounds der grad gehört habt werden
von der katze von c4 18 gemacht seht ihr
als acht werde nicht kennt das ist der
ersteller der komplett musik in
minecraft der ganz normalen musik von
anfang bis ende
von alfa bis zur jetzigen mir so hat er
die ganze musik gemacht und als gas
sound hat er einfach seine katze
aufgenommen während sie ein bisschen
wütend
ein gemacht hat und ja ich denke das
wusste ziemlich keiner von euch habt
auch gerade erst im internet gelesen von
dieses recht rechten sehr sehr sehr sehr
doll interessant und so freuen und das
war es nun auch mit der ersten folge von
minecraft galt also wie schon am anfang
gesagt der minecraft besteht aus drei
dingen die ihr eventueller nicht über
minecraft ist und mit einem fun fact der
dort drin auch noch enthalten ist also
ihr könnt mir sowas in die kommentare
schreiben
beziehungsweise eure minecraft gehen den
ich dann auch beim nächsten mal an haben
werde eventuell ich weiß nicht wie viele
es geht weder um mir ungefähr senden
werden und eventuell dann nächstes mal
auch mit bisschen unterstützung von
cartel media der mine versuchskaninchen
für manche sachen sein wird und die neue
mein leben freunde ich wirklich auf
jeden fall bei den daumen hoch freund
schaffen wir 1000 daumen hoch ich weiß
es eine menge dabei können wir das
eventuell schaffen ich weiß wir können
es schaffen können wir schaffen ja wir
schaffen das ok meine lieben freunde
euch noch ein wunderschöner tag ich
spreche hier zu schnell bis zum nächsten
mal